today's twin starter matt shoemaker
he has struggled with location and
that's the reason for the 10 home runs
that he's allowed among among other
things he has just got
got to find location with mainly
fastball and that split finger
changing
one and two
and that's chopped up the middle
and
that retires the first inning good
inning for matt shoemaker
lucas giolito
the struggle you look at the stats he
struggled a bit
he will throw fastballs up in the zone
he'll throw a lot of fastballs he's
gonna see if he can hit with a slider
here
arise at first there it is and that was
a brilliant slider tight slider for
strike three on polanco
toward the hole and off the tip of
anderson glove crews has a base hit
and arrives will advance to second base
[Applause]
change of fluttered in there for strike
three
wonderful pitch by giolito to end the
first scoreless no score bases empty two
outs
to center and deep
and
gone
another home run for nelly cruz against
giolito
a liner that just missed
the extended wall in right center field
when they retrieve this baseball there
may be green paint on it here you hit
the ball well last time
hopefully more the same as you can look
at another splinter
that was middle middle and garcia ropes
it to right center field let's see where
he ends up garcia to second base
as kepler gets it in it's a leadoff
double for garcia who's really started
to swing a better bat the last week
eaton to short polanco's got a hustle
save he beat it out cenote says he had
the ball and the bag for now we're tied
at one and we'll see what the twins do
with the challenge well i think he did
have the ball the question is did he
have the bag and john lipka the umpire
at first base
is saying that either he beat it or the
foot was not on the back
big effort by
and a great stretch by snow could very
well be that the foot did come off the
bag he's safe at first anyway whether
the foot came off the bag or not adam
eaton was hustling down the line it'll
go as a base hit it'll go as a tie game
and a lot of hustle by adam eaton tied
up the ball game
three and two
fastball got him pinpoint strike three
two two change down to a knee and two
gone
eight strikeouts for lucas
he's been in command that straight
change has been outstanding today
that ball is tagged to right field and a
hit for jake lamb up the alley way
garlic had to go cut it off deep and
lamb his head long into second base with
a lead-off double in a tie game in the
sixth
here's garcia
first pitch shot down the left field
side toward the corner it goes this is
fair off the wall garcia brings home the
lead run for the sox
and it's 2-1
in minneapolis
still a very good result to this point i
think he's going to look back at this
performance and hopefully it ends in a
win i know he's certainly hoping that
but he's going to realize he might have
turned the corner with the stuff today
to first vaughan stabs it gets to tim
double play on the return pass
beautifully done by andrew vaughan and
the socks without a bray you get a
brilliant effort at first
struck him out on the change up no
matter lucas gets strikeout number nine
oh he's torpedoed by the change up ten
strikeouts for giolito
check swing he won strike three
strikeout number 11 for giolito today
here it is there's a line drive caught
by the shortstop anderson
giolito through eight has given up just
two hits he's got 11 strikeouts guessing
that will be it
for the starter today we go to the night
and for the twins jorge alcana will get
the ninth in
looking for some consistency with that
good stuff that he has good fastball
good slider good change up
has yet to have a series of outings
where
one red bat
one batter after another he's punishing
with
with good strikes just nine hits allowed
but four of them home runs here's the
first pitch fly ball
getting lazily out to center
and
it's warnick with the call in to catch
garcia quickly retired 101
2-2
chopper to third
donaldson
across two down
[Music]
the ground ball
and a quick inning for alcohol we'll see
if the twins can have
the game tied up maybe have back-to-back
walk-offs on the bottom of the knife
looking at the numbers for lucas giolito
they don't tell the whole story but
they're very impressive eight innings
with a run on two hits three walks and
11 strikeouts
and he turns it over to liam hendricks
who's looking for his ninth save in his
11th opportunity
right back at it dayside today and the
02 strikes him out back shoe slider for
round number one one out nelson cruz
high in the air left hand side
tim will leave it to garcia who makes
the case jim couldn't see it and it's a
really good thing that leary could he's
saying hey jim i saw this one no problem
i got your pal
two two
he struck him out
sucks win the series eight innings from
geo and a 2-1 final score well liam
hendricks did exactly what liam
hendricks does he comes in the toughest
part of the order goes one two three the
conor mcgregor strut which is always
good but what a ball game it was and and
the best thing to come out of it besides
the win and win the series is lucas
giolito rediscovered whatever it was
that he was missing